foreign
Washington what's up Bros
hi thank you for taking my call you got
it near far I love that name do people
give you uh never mind all right okay
let's go let's go let's do this what's
up
all right so a little bit of background
kind of just where I'm at I'm a senior
in college going to school full-time
um I'm blessed to be on a sports
scholarship and an academic scholarship
so thanks to that and your guys's
program I'll be graduating in May
debt-free wow very cool
and I'm also working part-time and I
know that I have a lesson year left and
in the whole scheme of life like the
eight next eight months is really short
but I'm exhausted yeah I was gonna say
do you sleep every other Saturday
I try to
what are you what are you studying
animal science
animal science what are you gonna be
when you grow up
um
I have a focus in animal nutrition so
are you gonna go to that school
no are you going to work with like
gluten-free cows
yeah yeah
very cool when somebody brings their dog
in they're like we want to have a keto
dog you're like you came to the right
place yeah yeah no more not not pets so
what is that what is an animal
nutritionist do
um like design feed programs for cattle
operations pretty much
I thought
that rain fell and grass grew I thought
that was the feed operation so I'm glad
there are people like you out in the
world Rose making sure we have food to
eat because it feels up to me we would
all die that's fantastic okay so
um you're exhausted
and you got eight months till the finish
line and you and I both know that's not
how the world works because right when
you get to the Finish Line then you're
gonna have to have a job and move and
start a new job and life just goes crazy
ER
um so what are you gonna do
no I have as far as like after college
nope like for the next eight months
keep my head down and just threw it is
the goal that's the worst thing to do
rose don't just put your head down in a
deal I'm just kidding if that's what you
got to do if that's what you choose to
do
um what what sports are you doing
yeah I'm on the soccer team okay
and that season runs through the spring
huh
mm-hmm oh so you all haven't really
started yet have you
we haven't had a few games but it's not
full swing yet okay
here's what I've seen a million times
um
in the next month or two if you haven't
already you're gonna start thinking like
really kicking into gear about Life
After College
where am I gonna live what's my job
going to be do you already have a job
lined up or have you started that
process yet
I've started it but it's not official
yet okay
um
all right here's the deal we could if
you if you get to the finish line and
you collapse
you're gonna be no good to you you're
not going to be good to the new employer
that's going to pick you up you're not
going to be good to those animals that
you're serving Downstream you see what
I'm saying and so what we want to do is
to create a life worth living amidst the
chaos that is the last year of a
Collegiate athlete who's also working
part-time who's also filling the blank
fill in the blank fill in the blank
Okay so
let's step all the way back on in order
of importance you gotta graduate right
you got to make your grades and you're
on scholarships you got to keep a
certain grade right
at this point in your career how hard is
that
it's getting harder to keep up with it
all okay
do you have to play sports I think it
was my junior year when I quit I was a
track athlete and I I quit I was doing a
lot of work to potentially run One race
in one event and yeah it just ultimately
I I quit
um do you have to keep playing
I don't have to you know
do you want to
um
I I do enjoy it and it is something that
I really connect with my parents over so
that's
worth what it is I guess
um but it's not worth your sanity it's
not worth your sanity
okay
what about this 20-hour week job
hopefully turn into a bigger job down
the road so I'd like to hang on to that
it might turn into a bigger job down the
road Maybe
and it might be just a great gig so
here's what I'm doing I'm I'm want to
look at all the things that take up your
time in your schedule
and I want to be really honest with
myself and say hey look I'm really
talented in a lot of things because you
are
and I can do a lot of things
for the next eight months for my senior
year in college what do I need to do to
be successful at the next stage
because the party life and the fun life
and the yeah traveling around like that
that part has to come to an end at some
point and you and I both know you've
probably got a couple of people who
graduated one or two years ago that
still hang around
yeah yeah because they can't let it go
and we also have people like me who
after their freshman sophomore year
they're like dude I was high school hero
it's time like I'm not gonna I'm not
going to the Olympics and I'm not that
I'm not going to do that well even in a
regular meet
um it's time
foreign
I don't know what that looks like for
you but here's what I'm telling you
something sounds like it's got to give
you sound exhausted
and if your body and mind aren't well
the rest of this stuff doesn't work
right
um have you been struggling with
running low
or have you been more anxious than usual
okay has something else happened I
definitely feel like relationally
um
no not necessarily not
I mean there's always relational
struggles I feel like
I think huge tell me if I'm off here
and I can be way off I'm throwing
something up against the wall here tell
me if I'm wrong
for a lot of the college athletes that
I've spent time with I was like I said I
was one but I spent a lot of time with
them over the years
and a lot of high performing students
who make great great great grades
the ones that were not going on to med
school or to law school or to some sort
of doctoral program
as they got to the end of their senior
year they had a crisis and here was the
crisis and you mentioned it
I am who I am because of the grades I
make and how I perform on an athletic
field
and the things that my parents have
drilled into me since I was four is
academic success and athletic
performance and achievement
and I'm getting your body knows that you
are about to run out of relational
capital
and it starts to Rattle the cage a bit
because we don't know who we are without
these two things and these two things
are eight months away and Ticking
yeah
and if I don't have sports
I don't know
it's it's kind of like whenever kids
leave and Mom and Dad
have looked at look at each other like
who are you
that's what your body sounds like it's
starting to feel
and there has been no preparation for
anything other than we're gonna make
good grades so that you can go get the
job of your dreams and make money or
whatever and you're going to do great on
the sports field because what because
it's so so fun for parents to tell their
friends that their kids are on a
scholarship
yeah you know what I mean
and I would love to hear I want to hear
you say and I'm not saying you do this
okay I just want you to practice this
pretend I'm your mom and dad
and tell me that you've chosen for the
last semester to not play soccer
okay
that that will be a hard conversation to
have no practice with me right now hey
Rose what's up what are you calling for
um I am not playing soccer next semester
[Laughter]
it's gonna rip the Band-Aid off of that
one
yeah I hate you and I'm never coming
home bye right
um
is that a terrifying conversation or a
scary comment I mean what would the
response be back
supported the or supportive of it and I
feel like they'll also feel disappointed
maybe
where's that story coming from because I
don't know if that's true
um
this sports or soccer I think is
something like that we've connected over
like it's
my parents and so did not have that I'll
have to find something else here's
here's
um how old are you
I'm 22. okay you're 22.
I want you to practice the hardest adult
conversation you've probably had
and I want you to model it off what my
12 year old son did I think I've talked
about this on the show but when my 12
year old son did
um I think it was a year ago now
he knows that his dad is an obsessive
Houston Astros fan and we go to games
together and we go to Minor League games
here in Nashville and we play catch and
he played baseball by baseball and
played baseball and he's actually pretty
good
and he called a family meeting and me
and my wife went into the meeting and we
were like wow I have a 12 year old
already calling family meetings this is
cool
it was not cool and he said
I don't want y'all to be disappointed
but
I would really like to not play baseball
this spring and instead I want to do
theater
and we're so I've never been more proud
of him
because I know how hard that was for him
and of course I was excited it was a
little bit weird right I had to mourn it
because I envisioned myself as a
baseball dad
and I don't give a crap you know how
much fun I had watching him at the play
it was the best watching him studies
lines and get all into character I loved
it loved it loved it loved it he just
got a part in this year's play uh
yesterday two days ago
so I would love you to model it like
this Rose I'd love you to call your
parents
or go see them in person and say I'm
scared to have this conversation because
I think you're going to be disappointed
in me
or I'm scared to have this conversation
because I don't think you'll be
disappointed but all we've ever
communicated really connected on is
soccer and for the last semester I've
got to focus on my grades and I've got
to focus on this internship and I gotta
focus on my mental health because I'm
about to take it the the biggest leap of
my life into the Working World
and I don't want to play soccer this
last semester and I'm worried you're
going to be disappointed in me I want
you to say it just like that adult to
adult to adult
I want you to go for it that way
and it may not be soccer it may be hey
I've got to drop this internship or hey
I can't come home over the break I'm
running too much too hot
um can I drop down to 15 hours but I'm
going to need 200 a month or whatever
you're getting paid to help cover that
Gap but I can't go forward at this pace
at this schedule and be a good scholar
be a good student be a good the person I
want to be I can't be any of these
things if I've got this much crap going
on
okay
have this big hard hard
parent to child conversation that's
going to be one of the first ones if not
the first one that's adjusts to adult
to adult
and let us know how this conversation
goes I'm proud of you Rose you're almost
there you're gonna make it